[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN MORRIS: Hey, I'm Ben
Morris from the AMP team
live here in Amsterdam
at AMP Conf 2018.
We've seen talks today
from a wide variety
of people using AMP
for a whole bunch
of different applications.
Let's see some highlights.
SPEAKER 1: In the
last year or so,
we've seen that
sites everywhere have
seen great success with AMP.
Sites across verticals
and across the world
have been able to boost
their revenue by using AMP.
SPEAKER 2 : This is just
numbers based on DoubleClick Ad
Exchange and AdSense.
And we're seeing an increase
of 318% in terms of impressions
and 3x increase in ad revenue.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 3: With AMP, we
have to talk about, like,
what should we actually AMP?
And to do that, there are
a couple of challenges
that we needed to figure
out about which pages
we should consider.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But we were left with the
question, to AMP or not to AMP?
SPEAKER 4: Reddit
has been growing,
which makes Google SEO, and
especially AMP, very, very
important for us.
SPEAKER 3: We wanted to reap
all the benefits that AMP
had to offer, but
we wanted to ensure
that our tracking remained
accurate and insightful.
SPEAKER 5: Maybe you are one
of our ecosystem providers,
and you do ads, analytics, or
you produce embeddable content.
You want to make sure your
products are AMP-enabled.
Well, it's really
easy to do that too.
SPEAKER 6: I do love [? house ?]
pages, and when AMP came up,
I thought, OK, let's just
try this for e-commerce,
see where we are going.
You start your
journey and think,
OK, where should
I start with AMP?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 7: Thank you very much.
Hopefully it's time to
maximize your own results.
BEN MORRIS: That's a wrap
from here at AMP Conf
2018 right here in Amsterdam.
If you missed any
of the talks, you
can still find those in
the AMP Conf playlist,
right here on the
AMP YouTube channel.